[Music]
good
[Music]
donald trump oh yes the time has come
joe biden's brain has been dead for
years now
now you donald trump need to bring what
remains of joe biden to my embalming
parlor
my undercrowder and i have been making
preparations
we just need you to finish the job oh
yes
donald trump your time is running out
i will be watching on the ladder with
crowder debate stream the souls of the
american people will all be watching
bearing witness as you deliver that
fatal blow
to rapey joe biden it can only be you
president trump and as you stand in
victory
your opponent will rest in
peace
hey oh i'm here i had no idea the screen
was just totally dark i thought we were
just going with a dark direction for the
show well somebody is getting terminated
and our next guest probably knows
something about that because he's been
head honcho for a while uh we are going
to come back
after this guest of course we'll be
doing pre-gaming as a little bit of a
tradition with our drinking game rules
costume contests tonight's theme is back
to the town hall where we'll be watching
donald trump
and then tuning to the joe biden town
hall during the commercial break so that
uh we get to fact check them but
not give them any ratings uh and then
we'll switch over when the town hall is
done but right now
you know him you love him he is
america's mayor and he is the
top dog in the news right now uh former
mayor of new york city and times
magazine
man of the year uh and i call him
i would like to say friend but he's been
on the show once but mayor giuliani how
are you sir
how are you then i am doing fine thank
you very much so uh
seems like you're a busy man these days
i'd say so
yeah i'm busy but it's it's good we're
finally getting the truth out
yeah once in a while but we're finally
getting it out well
we'll get in to that in a second not
getting it out as much as one
could if not for you know today's roman
empire which is big tech but before we
go into
the hunter biden emails and all of that
uh what do you expect from each town
hall
tonight and of course by the way sorry i
should have mentioned uh the the podcast
is common sense available at
rudy's common sense dot com i'm sorry i
figured people know you have a podcast
but it's common sense
with rudy giuliani what do you expect
tonight from the town halls
first donald trump then uh joseph biden
well i mean donald trump has done so
many of them i think we all know
what's going to happen he'll be he'll be
very transparent he's got
tremendous command of the issues the
substantive issues
um he'll answer the questions directly
he's not going to not going to say you
don't deserve to know my position
on whatever which biden is likely to say
whatever is kind of a placeholder but it
works in this instance because
it has been pretty much used for
whatever well i mean yeah it'll be uh
biden who knows what we're going to get
with biden i don't know if he's taken a
sufficient number of
drugs i guess he'll get through it if he
hasn't he'll forget the pledge of
allegiance
do you pledge allegiance to the flag uh
you know
right whatever uh do you okay we'll move
that's that's kind of you just threw
some bombs out there like
you threw like it was a molotov cocktail
at a uh at a peaceful protest
do you really think that former vice
president joe biden is using performance
enhancing drugs and obviously this is
conjecture but if you had to bet
i think he's taking something like
adderall to help his concentration
because there are times in which he
wanders off into who knows where
and there are other times where he's
pretty focused and i mean i've spoken to
doctors about it including a podcast i
did on it
both doctors said that from everything
they can see
he looks like he's pretty far advanced
with dementia
some of the some of the prime symptoms
being he gets numbers screwed up
he gets lost in the middle of sentences
he can't remember who his wife is he
thinks he was in the center for 186
years
he thinks he's running for the senate
well he said the other day of running
for the senate he didn't even pause i
mean it's like
yeah we might make that mistake i'm
running to the senate no no
right you know i'm running for the
senate i was in the center for a hundred
years you'd think there'd be a forehead
slap somewhere along that
president
[Laughter]
but by how how amazing would it be if
this was all one brilliant ploy just to
convince his wife that i didn't know she
wasn't you
i forgot who you are you saw me do it on
a national stage
i think it's going to be an insanity
defense in his ricoh case
right okay so let's get to this this is
uh i have to ask you some some
questions that obviously people want to
see asked both from the right and left
but
surmi is here for people who don't know
because a lot of people get their
information from facebook and twitter
and the story uh was throttled we tested
it by the way
it was the first time i think i was ever
retweeted by the the president we tested
uh the new york post article about your
hunter buying emails and it told us that
it could not be posted we have the
screenshot available on my twitter
because it violated their uh their
policies
and then it was sort of disseminated and
jack dorsey apologized he'll have to
speak before hearing
so for people who haven't heard yet this
is a bombshell in new york post
uh what is it if you have to give them
the bullet points hunter biden joe biden
what's the implication here hunter biden
uh
and joe biden are involved in a bribery
scheme in
in ukraine and hunter biden and joe have
for years said that joe knew nothing
about barisma the company that paid the
bribe
uh they he knew nothing about his
dealings in
in uh in ukraine and what what there is
is a
cold clear uh group of text messages in
which hunter biden sets up a meeting
for the number two person in that
company with joe biden
right who then checks hunted back and
thanks him so it makes joe a complete
liar for the last seven years
it shows that he met with barisma um
i think he um it's not on his public
schedule
but we have another one where uh hunter
biden was snuck into the back of the
state department so he's meeting with
the deputy secretary of state
tony blinken isn't reported because if
he had the meeting
it would have violated the foreign
agents registration act
so they i mean there are plenty of um
very very damning things with regard to
ukraine on the on the hard drive the
main one being that
joe biden's been lying for seven years
about it and knew all about
uh barista as as as you knew was true
what you got to do
just saying you know anything about my
son's foreign dealings
how credible is that right the guy is
suffering from really massive
drug addiction which the hard drive will
make clear it's hard to get through
a line of photographs without seeing one
of him with a crack
pipe sitting in a carpet well he was a
fan of
weeds in the closet going bonkers he's
like a zombie
have you seen the pictures have you seen
the pictures of him with the crack pipe
did john right i have oh wow does he
look at least look
like cool unfortunately i can't show
them to you right now but this is the
hard drive they're on
right there oh my word let me ask you
this uh mayor giuliani
how did you get that hard drive because
this is this is the crux of the new york
uh the new york post article being
thrown right on social media
they said that you've been working with
a russian agent uh or that it's entirely
false
actually i got it directly from putin
you are not going to believe who likes
hash pipe
again putin sent it to me and he said um
i don't even know he actually just
wanted a couple of bottles of vodka in
return which wasn't bad i mean it cost
me about 150 bucks i sent it to putin
right and um if you send him something
better than grey goose he'll show you
the herald
in there with the crack pipes it's got
him there
uh doing an imitation of anthony weiner
about 50 times
um you know you know what i'm talking
about right
it's got some very disturbing things on
it that i shouldn't joke about
and yeah here's how i got it hunter
biden
brought his hard drive into a repairman
to repair it the repairman took it
hunter biden signed a receipt for it
which i have here
uh and said he would have to he was
going to come back for it
two days later he came back and gave him
a part and then when it was done he
never came back
according to the agreement after 90 days
the hard drive
is abandoned under the law and it
belongs to the merchant
the merchant held it for another three
four months and then he heard all this
talk on television
and and he started to get worried what
do i have here this could be criminal
evidence
right so we opened it he opened it and
he almost fainted
he said i know i never saw anything like
this before
the uh and if you looked at the if you
look at the photographs
you'd probably come to that conclusion
also but then he took a look at the text
and he saw her in the text
major contradictions to what the bidens
were saying on television like
like the one i just told you right was
saying i didn't know anything about
barista in ukraine and there's plenty of
evidence that he could can i ask you a
question mayor giuliani because
you know you mentioned anthony weiner
and you know i sort of came up under
andrew breitbart was
before it was breitbart it was big
hollywood and i was there for the wiener
scandal and acorn and all that
here's my question to you because
obviously you know that the left is
going to come out and say
well this can't be corroborated that's
the basis on which facebook and twitter
have
throttled this story despite the fact
that they were covering stories that
were verifiably false regarding trump
calling the troops
luck suckers and losers but how do you
um how do you go about them behind the
scenes making sure that new york post or
have you offered any evidence to anyone
other than new york post to corroborate
because
obviously new york post believes that
this is real they've confirmed it but is
there any way for you to get the media
to confirm it behind the scenes
so that we don't run a follow-up social
media or do they not care if
if they think it's not correct through
rupert murdoch
you don't i mean he he had it for five
days
and they did everything they could to
verify it they're convinced that it's
real
not only that i internally verified it i
i there are there are things on that
hard drive that only hunter biden would
know
because those things were given to us by
uh anonymous informants dates for
example that aren't public
dates of meetings that were never
recorded in the state department of the
white house
in order to hide them and the hard drive
comes up with exactly those same dates
that would only have been known to
hunter biden uh
his pictures all over it make it pretty
clear that it's him
his signature is on the receipt for it
uh the gentleman can identify him as
hunter biden
uh and if you read if you read the
intern if you read the internal um
messages they're quite consistent with
what we already know
it describes the transaction uh
describes a transaction in china that i
think we all know it's in
schweiker's book almost exactly the same
as schweicher
does it except it explains that when the
money was transferred uh the ukraine
thing is
exactly what the five witnesses told me
all of whom want to come to the united
states and testify under oath and are
being blocked
from coming to the united states and um
i mean this is really ridiculous i mean
this is mammoth obviously like this
makes this makes water
gate look like uh uh what do we say
dwarf piss droplets at this point
it's so huge that it almost seems um
almost for lack of a better word it
almost it almost sounds unbelievable to
americans because like well this this is
so huge and that's why twitter and
facebook have decided to throttle it
which
hopefully at this point we understand
that this is now a first amendment issue
and not a free speech version of the
first amendment issue but we're talking
about actually the freedom
of the press if new york post is not
being allowed to get their material up
there one thing i wanted to
make sure you and you may not know how
to explain this because it's more of a
tech issue
your story obviously or the story the
new york post story that you've
obviously provided information on
was not available when we were searching
at social media uh
all across platforms what was was a
story
that claimed you or someone who worked
with you
had photoshopped these files or had
fabricated them so that wasn't
considered fake news
that was at the top and that's not even
the claim they're making yeah as a
matter of fact i have my
guy bryce i'm willing to invite i i mean
i just
invited uh someone on fox if they want
to come here and look at it
they can't take it away but come and
look at it figure out for yourself today
i actually have my tech guy bryce here
who explained to me why those articles
were false
right off the bat if i may and you were
saying that there's something so it's
not
super you know super definitive right
but it's just an explanation
yeah uh gibbon you want to pull up the
uh raster verse vector thing okay so
just we'll explain it really quickly
because
yeah so their argument was that the
little logo was
pixelized and all kind of low resolution
compared to the text but uh
that's that's kind of what would happen
if you exported
an email okay yeah uh
so vector so so the little icon is
usually like an apple
or a google type image right and that's
probably referencing either a
vector or higher resolution images on
the server
it's okay it sounded like mayor that's
exactly what happened
this is this was an older this was an
older
the original hard drive was older and he
had to put it on
newer hard drives i mean he can explain
it
in detail and and come on let's face it
they're not challenging the accuracy of
well they're not anymore
in fact i'll give you something that
really verifies it
the very morning this came out within
about 20 minutes
hunter biden's lawyer called the
merchant
and asked him if he could have the hard
drive back really
yeah well that's uh yeah that also
reminds me i need to call geek squad
we have the email evidence of that wow
wow that's the lawyer who's asking for
the hard drive back
well so if they obviously verify that
it's the heart hey you can leave bryce
yeah i'm talking america's mayor i
apologize for that he was
he overstays his welcome um that is now
is that is there any record of that
in other words like the lawyer reaching
out to this man i would imagine yeah
yeah
there's he actually did it by uh
telephone and by email we have the email
good look it's almost as though it makes
it worse on them
oh yeah the dumbest thing a lawyer can
do but who says that
would you advise your job with the
dumbest kid in law school
if someone
the dumbest kid in our law school class
but he's a nice guy
he cheated his way through oh my
plagiarized in law school
all right well mr uh mayor giuliani we
uh we're gonna have to get going here
pretty soon but let me ask you is there
uh what else can we expect
obviously the relations now with china
and the leverage that uh china could
have
on a joe biden presidency uh came out
today
what else do you think peop is going to
most surprise people since
you're kind of you know this is a drip
drip from this hard drive what is there
something can you give us
i think i think uh i think as the second
transaction in
china comes out you're going to see him
being involved with a
chinese communist operative an
intelligence operative and it's quite
obvious that he's setting him up he's
setting
hunter biden up and he's setting joe up
for extortion
i think there'll be more emails and text
messages that make that clear
i think you're going to see more emails
and text messages that
describe how joe was compensated how he
was getting a portion of this money
in fact he was getting a large portion
of this money and
it'll explain also how joe biden who
never really made much money
has two or three very very luxurious
homes
right because he didn't pay for anything
hunter did so
um this is a long-term bribery scheme
that started at a low level in delaware
with his brother james
selling his office holding the money
taking care of joe
and when they got to the big time they
shook down iraq for
i think about 500 million uh ukraine for
about
20 china i don't know i mean 30 40
million
right oh oh oh gosh i missed russia the
3.5 million from the
mayor's wife who was a good friend by
the way we're kidding around about putin
that woman is a close ally of putin so
we have the irony that
we the president was accused of falsely
of colluding with
russia but biden actually got paid by
russia well
i'll give you one more when the media or
you know i say media but i'm talking
about twitter and facebook but let's be
honest that's what the media really is
now i don't watch cable news anymore
because my doctor
told me was a hypochondriac that i
didn't have mesothelioma so i went
just to social at that point i'm sure
but i need i need a reverse mortgage doc
he's like don't listen to tom selleck it
actually is his first rodeo
but um my question to you
here is um this is unbelievable when you
think about the fact that they fact
checked this not fact check said well we
can't verify the source but you just
mentioned russia
people forget there was a story about
donald trump washing russian prostitutes
peeing on furniture
and there was no verification and none
of that was ever throttled so
um i am really looking forward and he's
a germaphobe
[Laughter]
i've known him 30 years i knew that was
false the day they said it
he wouldn't get within 10 miles or
something like that
unless like beforehand he had his
assistants go in like greeks and put the
cellophane back over the furniture and
he would still be like oh
gross no i didn't buy it either um the
show is common sense it's the podcast
available at rudy's commonsense.com
you can follow uh mayor giuliani at rudy
giuliani
on the twitter as long as they still
allow him
i really appreciate you doing this and
uh i know you're staking your reputation
on this
day by day now on twitter okay okay well
thank you so much uh majoliani we really
appreciate it and uh i'll be uh
keeping everyone abreast and talk with
you soon you're a lot of fun thank you
god bless and uh you know what i know we
had a cut here ready you can let uh a
mayor go
we had a cut ready on amy coney barrett
but you know what we don't have time for
that right now
okay so we are going to bring in gerald
and half asian bill to give our
pre-town hall thoughts and uh here's the
intro let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh hello we are back the town hall is
about to start right next to me
is uh doc uh i forget his name doc what
doc what
brown brown doc brown brown my half
asian lawyer bill richmond who could
have been an extra in the film i guess
and um if
in the last uh 24 hours uh it's not the
rona it's food poisoning
so if you see me leave today at any
point during the town hall
it's you know i just had to interview
one of the most famous mayors of all
time and i'm just think please don't
poop please don't
please don't poop please don't poop you
and joe biden think the same thing
so you're basically in his shoes well he
just he's just hoping that the pens
don't give
a dead dead giveaway with the sound uh
looks like they're gonna be starting
this town hall here any second uh the
drinking game rules let's bring them up
really quickly
is what is i can't read them yeah trump
gets a leading or unfair question
drops the thug life moment says china or
fake news and finish your drink if trump
mentions hunter biden
oh lord and you will hear this ding
there you go the promo code
is uh again just trying not to poop
it's not written
hashtag that's the promo code you get 20
off for the next 24 hours and what we'll
be doing is during the commercial
break reg the bandit is here we will go
to the biden town hall
and fact check it so you get two town
halls one stream
and then after uh this town hall ends
there's another full half hour of the
biden town hall
hey look we have let's give our thoughts
during the first commercial break we
have uh savannah guthrie
so george stephanopoulos are in the
biden town hall who was a uh democratic
communications director
she's just married to one oh let's see
what she has to say
in a virtual debate at that point joe
biden scheduled a town hall tonight in
pennsylvania on another network and now
the president way to send people to your
competition yeah what the hell
oh obviously the costume contest by the
way guys
really quickly do you what do you expect
tonight well you know hold on she's
gonna have donald trump he's right there
we'll
we'll watch and we'll shut up and then
we'll talk over uh joe biden because
it's nonsensical
taking questions from voters here in
miami who we should mention are socially
distanced and they're wearing masks and
i
should say this audience looks a bit
like america they began wearing masks
once we yelled action
it was like it's changed my mind no one
was wearing a mask
including the people who walked up to
talk with me and i always ask hey would
you like me to wear a mask and i go
yes i do it's like i just watched you
yeah i just watched you inhale someone's
cough like it was an essential oil
eucalyptus thank you all right here we
go glad you're here we're glad you're
well
we send our best to the first lady into
baron thank you do you
have any remaining you're not glad
nothing whatsoever i'm
great i feel good i was in north
carolina today and did a big
rally with tremendous turnout and i just
feel really good
florida pennsylvania we're all over the
place it's been
great you received some treatments that
are generally
reserved for those with the most severe
form of the disease
in particular did you have pneumonia
well i'll tell you what happened uh
i didn't feel good i didn't feel strong
i had a little bit of a temperature the
doctors at the white house are fantastic
as you can imagine and
they really didn't want to take a chance
and they said let's go to the hospital i
said that's okay i'm going to
you know respond to what you say and we
went over to walter reed where you have
tremendous professionals
they gave me regeneron and rem desavier
both
and i just all i know is i felt good the
following day i felt really good
did the doctors ever tell you that they
saw pneumonia on your lungs no but they
said the lungs are you know a little bit
different a little bit uh
pneumonia
i don't know i mean i didn't do too much
asking i i really felt good
i didn't have much of a problem with the
lens i did have a little bit of a
temperature
obviously i felt there was something
missing and then i tested you know i
tested possibly probably talking about
testing because there's a little bit
i guess confusion about this and i think
we can clear it up and there should be
your first positive test was thursday
october 1st
okay when was your last negative test
when did you last remember having a
negative test well i test quite a bit
and i can tell you that before the
debate which i thought it was a very
good debate
and i felt fantastically i was i had no
problem
before did you test the day of the
debate i don't know i don't even
remember i test all the time but i can
tell you this uh
after the debate like i guess a day or
so
i think it was thursday evening maybe
even late thursday evening
uh i tested positive that's when i first
found out
back to the debate that was after you
licked
they give you a perfect answer but they
take a test and i leave and i go about
four minutes
yeah by the way the doctor's already
come out they're trying to catch him and
say
he's lying about kobe because i know i'm
trying to say that he had it before the
debate
for the debate and it was only after the
debate
like a period of time after the debate
that
the government of the vehicle being the
dumbest president ever
was uh covertly engaging in biological
warfare
but you know the doctor is very accurate
information and it's not only that
doctor it's many doctors the one thing
as you
if you're president you have a lot of
doctors you're surrounded by
but i was in great shape for the debate
and sometime
after the debate i tested positively
this is a good time
that's when they decided to answer
abruptly
to showcase clarity nonsensical yeah
held at the white house on the saturday
before you tested positive
subsequent to that 13 people connected
to that event let's drink every time
they asked about his coconut
drink really you've seen the pictures
there was an interest
people were not wearing they're not a
real doctor my question to you is
at this point in the pandemic knowing
what we know
shouldn't you have known better
shouldn't the white house have little
arrows going
like that oh my god a lot of testing in
the white house they test everybody
including me but they test everybody
catch it so yeah
that's what i heard and that's what i
saw and regardless
everybody's tested and they're tested
often and i also knew
that hey i'm president i have to see
people i can't be
in a basement i can't be in a room i
can't be i have to be out
you can see people with the mask though
right i can
but people look like you put on
the
he ground had a mask and they caught it
well there are pictures of tom tillis
actually with one of um judge barrett's
kids not wearing a mask but you know
chris christie
oh my god some people weren't wearing a
mask what a freaking nightmare
very sick he was in the hospital for
about a week he came out tonight and
said
i was wrong not to wear a mask no you
weren't
who said this i mean he has to say that
i think it's great he's a friend of mine
he's a good guy
and of course he should always come here
not wrong everything is related
and they would hug me and they would
touch me and
i'm not going to anyone out there
watching from the left okay just and
then we'll
let donald trump speak and uh of course
you can tune into the uh the town hall
yourself they can do a watch along
because they might try and boot us we've
had that happen with nbc
and if anyone out there can find me the
study
the study that exists or from the cdc if
you guys are so pro-science
find me a single study that shows that
the cotton masks you wear
made at home the way you wear them
meaning you don't wash them and sanitize
them after every single use
that that stops the spread of microbes
like cobit
find me a single study that says the
homemade cotton masks
if they are not washed on hot in a
hospital washing machine
every single use show me one study that
shows it works because two can play that
case
yeah exactly by the way that was a just
so you know i pulled the lawyer game i
didn't ask a question i don't know the
answer too
i can't be in the basement i can't be
locked in a very beautiful room
someplace in the white house
and i want to see the gold star families
and i want to see everybody
and i also say to people all the time
it's risky doing it it is risky doing it
you're right you don't want to you want
to be a leader leader in a setter of an
example
and if you're not wearing a mask when
your administration is saying i'd rather
be
painting the bowl in the office this is
insufferable
many people are getting by the way every
single question
[Music]
they've done a very good job but now you
take a look today at the uk you take a
look at spain and france and italy
there's tremendous spikes but our death
rate is worse
than well not spain but those other
countries right here that will tell you
exactly the opposite
percent but we have he brought his own
our deaths per capita
excess mortality we're a winner on the
excess mortality
and what we've done has been amazing
absolutely
the world health organization in cdc can
probably bring this up they estimate
that i think
750 million people have been infected
with kobe you can't just go by the test
they themselves don't use the test and
the deaths
for their measurement of the mortality
rate they use their overall estimates
where they take into account anybody's
house all of those
and when you take those into account the
united states is even better off on the
list i think it's 740 million might be
760 million
we can have red to the bandit or token
now and bring it up in a little bit
i could be off give or take that are
absolutely incredible i want to pick up
on something you just said you said
we're rounding the corner
i believe we're rounding the corner now
ten percent of the country approximately
has had coven that means
ninety percent is still vulnerable
there's been some talk including from
the white house can we get chris wallace
back
yeah yeah but he still has to sit on a
hat
but that woman owns no upper lip do you
support her i think it's invisible
as a strategy yes essentially i mean
kissing her would be one half a curb
cannot be worse than the problem itself
we did the right down
we were expected to lose 2 million 200
000 people and maybe more than that
we're at 210 000 people one person is
too much it should have never happened
because of china
it happened because of china yes i'll
drink it
in there right but it shouldn't i love
how he says my hope we were expected to
lose if you look at the original charts
from original doctors who are respected
by everybody two million
two hundred thousand two million figure
though it's if you literally tune in on
people
the two million figure is if you did
absolutely
what did he need to do to make it less
than a tenth of that
speech
mortality rate would you consider that
effective if you were one of the two
organizations going in one of them was
samaritan's purse who by the way were
supposed to vilify because franklin
right if you were going in with a 50
percent
survival rate with ebola in these other
countries i can't remember where they
were ebola
uh where was the uh the main outbreak of
ebola and some one of those after one of
you can remember exactly what it was
fifty percent and then because of the
actions taken by the organization it was
down to five percent would you not
consider that success
if you don't give me a number what's a
success five percent of the total number
one percent she's not doing that yeah
and you just keep moving the goal post
these were the numbers that we went off
of saying we've got to lock down the
economy right
right and he did take action that
resulted in 10 of the deaths
even if you count everyone on their
counter so that cure
that so-called cure that you talk about
it can't be worse
than the problem the problem is a bad
problem we've got more questions
so let's drop it for now we were
supposed to mention we were watching you
on a debate stage right now we're not
doing that so let's clear up a few
things from the last one
you were asked point blank to denounce
white supremacy
you didn't ask some follow-up questions
who specifically
a couple of days later on a different
show you denounced
for years but you always do it you
always start off with the kids
and he was asking questions like biden
was a child
well so this is a little bit of a dog
are you listening
[Music]
in fact my people came i'm sure they'll
ask you the white supremacy question
i denounce white supremacy and frankly
you want to know something
i denounce antifa and i denounce these
people on the left that are burdened
yeah i just don't know what i'm
denouncing let me out that's what i was
saying she was just agreeing
theory that uh democrats are
a satanic pedophile ring and that you
are the savior now can you just
once and for all state that that is
completely the media one not
media wonders why we don't take them
seriously donald trump wants to erode
trust in american institutions hold on a
second do you mean the institution that
for
nine minutes asked the president about
his personal covet test
which his doctors already clarified then
moved on to asking him to denounce white
supremacy which he did multiple times
and then moved on to asking him to
denounce a conspiracy theory
that the democrats are a satanic
pedophile death cult
this is the town hall about antifa and i
know about the radical left and i know
how violent they are
and i know how they are burning down
cities run by democrats not right
republican senator ben sasse said quote
q anon
is nuts and real leaders call conspiracy
theories
conspiracy theories are we talking about
crazy
he may be right i just don't know about
q anon you do know
i don't know no i don't know i don't
know let me ask you another thing
let's waste a whole show you do know
would that be considered
why aren't you asking me about the
radicals why are you asking joe biden
could you imagine being questioned that
you just want to eat your bacon egg
because she's gonna go off for 20
minutes about nitrites
that's so cute antifa
they're vicious they're violent they
kill people and they're burning down
absolutely and they happen to be my gosh
just this week you retweeted to your 87
million followers a conspiracy theory
that joe biden to have seal team six the
navy sealed to six killed to cover up
the the fake death of bin laden now why
would you send a lion
followers that was a retweet that was a
an opinion of somebody and that was a
retweet
i'll put it out there people can decide
for themselves i don't take a position
donald trump retweeted me a bunch of
times
i literally just called him an [ __ ]
in the most recent change in my mind
now he's our [ __ ] and i like him but
still he doesn't agree with everything
retweets i know that he doesn't agree
with this
i would after donald trump hard in the
primary media i wouldn't be able to get
the word out
why are we reporting at all
we're building our country stronger and
better than it's ever been before
and that's what's happening and
everybody knows that that's the word
winning in a lot of states i'm winning
in a lot of states let me ask
okay i'm glad you brought up the
election because i do want to ask you
about that
they're kind of left in the election a
lot of people have asked you
will you accept a peaceful transfer of
power
i don't know this election is if it is
rigged they didn't accept 2016. by the
way they were relying on the incoming
administration right you don't cover
that
and your lack of facebook say that it's
not verified let's talk more about uh
how he was watching
russian prostitutes right unsolicited by
the way
nightmare were you one of them the
millions and thousands of them are
dumped in dumpsters and
when you see ballots with the name trump
military ballots from our great military
and they're dumped in garbage cans
that's a handful we could go all night
no
this is [ __ ] you can go and watch
our article
our video that we did on mail and voting
there are two problems fraud
and an f system a system that just can't
handle now we've been telling it since
that segment because ohio just had
another
how many votes was it fifty thousand
votes compromise or was it it was it was
tens of thousands of
compromises the total tally of
potentially compromised votes as
recognized on the record legally it's
504
000 something over 504 000 votes could
either be
uh fraudulent could be compromised could
be from people who don't even
necessarily live at that address
that's the potential of them but think
of
of the margin of victory in certain
states particularly swing states you add
them all up go back to our segment we
went through pennsylvania we went
through georgia we went through texas
which by the way let's go to donald
trump it's just
half a million this is just what's next
why do i need my background
thousands of ballots dumped in a garbage
can and they happen to have my name on
it
i'm not happy about it but just i like i
like this whoever the audience member is
behind his left shoulder yeah
i like him about our democracy
i think it's a nodding model say that
you do read newspapers you do watch the
news i know you read the news but you
watch it i do
ballots um are corrupt that are
fraudulent and millions that are
are being processed right now but you
can win a race
that you and them talk about the
peaceful transfer
when i spent three and a half years
fighting off these maniacs
and now it turns out everything's there
that they were the ones that dealt with
russia
and it's too bad but peaceful transfer i
absolutely want that but ideally i don't
want to transfer because i want to win
yes and i think that your words will
probably reassure some folks let's get
to our first voter we've got jacqueline
lugo
i told you this as long as i smile
dishonest bitchiness is less
jacqueline what's your question for the
president and hold the mic up close and
take off your mic because it's hard to
hear out here
good evening how are you uh welcome to
miami
as you told bob woodward in february
as as what as you told bob woodward in
february
was airborne and deadlier than the flu
why did you only put in place
a travel ban from china and not put in
place
other measures mitigating the spread of
covet 19
potentially saving tens of thousands of
american lives
well i did put it in very early as you
know joe biden was two months behind me
and he called me xenophobic and racist
and everything else because i put it in
and it turned out that i was 100 right i
also put it on europe
very early because i saw there was a lot
of infection in europe
and it's sort of an amazing question and
i appreciate the question and respect
the question
but the news doesn't get out the right
answer because i put on a travel ban
far earlier than dr fauci thought it was
necessary who i like
far earlier than the scientist i was
actually the only one that wanted to put
it on and i did it
actually against the advice of a lot of
people including nancy pelosi
when she
nancy pelosi in chinatown we have the
entire timeline that i know i've gone
over ad nauseum
from february oh you have it thank you
very much okay
all right january 31st that's when they
announced the chinese travel ban
and then february 24th that's when
pelosi was saying you should go to
chinatown
february 29th that's when they announced
a level four travel advisory two areas
of italy south korea they barred all
travel to iran
barred the entry of foreign citizens who
visited visited ram the last 14 days
march 2nd after that bill de blasio
encourage new yorkers to go to movie
theaters march 4th
trump administration purchased about 500
million n95 respirators
and replenished the depleted stockpile
of ppe from barack obama march 6th
he signed an 8.3 billion dollar bill to
fight the cronus
chronovirus outbreak march 11th travel
restrictions on all of europe
march 13th declared a national emergency
in order to access 42 billion this goes
on and on and on all the way through
march and april
all the while de blasio nancy pelosi
were saying come on down to chinatown
and eat dumplings so we have that
timeline all the way up on our
on our website stephen did you see this
criminal on the screen
she's got no mask on oh my word mr trump
has a frontline er doctor working
through the coronavirus pandemic
i know firsthand and i've seen that many
hospitals throughout the united states
are suffering uh financial hardships
these
uh economic effects are trickling down
to the frontline workers we are being uh
across the country frontline workers are
being fired they're being furloughed our
salaries are being cut
and this is also happening in other
economic sectors as well including the
travel industry and hospitality you're
supposed to be
my question to you is the time you're
making a killing are you going to get
the united states back on track should
we clean it up
the health care workers the medical
establishment big pharma they want
everyone
they can make a lot of money well
there's plenty of people sick why aren't
you making your money oh that's right
you're gonna have a phenomenal third
not the virus but the idea of flattening
the curb which was to make sure the
hospital turned over burden
instead you guys are empty i'm sorry
but all the electives
houses so many things are happening so
people were saying we're going to have a
42 unemployment look
this was a thing that came into our
country
and it happened a hundred more than a
hundred years ago
and it happened now they were talking
about a 42
unemployment rate
7.8 unemployment and people can't even
believe it
our economy is going as a matter of fact
i will tell you this i think we have
this article from
washington post where the actual
advisors to joe biden democratic
advisers were planning on running
against the worst case scenario if
donald trump got unemployment down to 12
percent
well it was down to below eight at the
beginning of the quarter i don't know
what it is now i'm still falling forward
in the history of our country last year
including the state of florida where we
are now
going to be a 40 unemployment rate i
don't know the same people are there's
gonna be over two million dead
we had to close it down we saved two
million lives we're opening it up
we have a v-shape and it's coming back
it's coming back very fast
one other thing we really helped the
hospitals we've sent billions and
billions of dollars to the hospitals
in addition hundreds of millions of
masks
and gowns and we went into the
ventilator business because
this country was not equipped with
ventilators and i'm not blaming anybody
for it
but we're now making thousands of
ventilators a month
and we have all we can use we're sending
them all over the world because the
world needs them so
they've worked very hard and really very
very effectively thank you great
question
why aren't people complaining that uh i
don't know lithuania i didn't send us
masks
how about friends online healthcare
workers and i've seen the physical and
the mental tools that this pandemic has
taken
on them firsthand not to get into the
point that you guys are going to pay
your fair share of nato why is the
united states job to help the rest of
the world
and then why are we condemned when we
don't do it enough hey how about you
help hey canada
how about you send us how about you help
replenish the all of the ppe all of it
can you help can you help can you spare
some change
different stories on masks i mean i had
you know
being president you have people they
bring meals
and i had an instance recently where a
very wonderful person is bringing me a
meal and he's playing with his mask and
he's touching his mask
all over the place and then he's
bringing a plate in and i'm saying well
i don't know if that's so good
i mean the good news i didn't eat it
okay i did i decided not to eat it this
was a month ago but i look
look you have on the masks you know you
have two stories you have a story where
they want a story where they don't want
it
they're all in unison about it the
university of washington which is a stud
is a that you have a model that your
coronavirus task force relies on
says that if everyone wore a mask you
could cut expected depths
in half scott atkins
if you look at scott dr scott he's from
great guys stanford
and if nobody ever owned a gun you'd cut
down on
guns being the method used for suicide
by a lot but they just switched to pills
the reason you can't do it however is
because it's a right
it's a right you dumb harlot you can't
just mandate everyone wearing a mask and
you can't enforce it but it's this
is the problem not only do they live
as ideologues and pass themselves off as
journalists
but they're not even good ideologues do
you really think that
donald trump can bust down your door and
make sure you're wearing a mask
a cop can't even a cop can't even have
charges dropped for shooting someone who
charged him with a knife and a taser at
his face
you really think the government's going
to be capable of ensuring that every
single american follows an
unconstitutional mandate to wear a mask
by the way show me that study again show
me that study that shows
the cotton masks that you wear at home
provided
if you're not washing it every single
time the study doesn't count show me the
study that shows your little cotton mask
that you bought at lululemon
will stop the spread of the virus again
these studies are using n95 respirators
these studies are using
actual surgical masks that are either
being disper of which are being they're
being disposed
or they're using reusable masks that are
washed
in a high high temperature i believe it
has to be at least 180 degrees if i'm
not mistaken maybe it's 170 degrees
uh in a hospital commercial level
washing machine all right
let's go i think it's time to uh we uh
it's time for us to go actually over
to the biden town hall and fat check it
let's go
well that was a thrill oh yeah yeah we
got there there we go
are we at an actual town hall because i
the last channel i was concerned
it seemed like we were in a freaking
debate she was a very adversary you know
i volunteered with special needs people
at a church it's called friendship club
yeah you're an ass i felt like i was
there and trump was the counselor
uh let's bring up the biden town hall a
fact checker whatever is going on here
reg the bandit
is there uh what is going on what have i
missed
what has happened with the biden town
hall
well we haven't had a lot except
coronavirus talk
okay and then a little bit about um race
we had a young black voter
ask biden what he could offer him
but i think the main fact-checking
points that we have we've got
um biden first said that trump uh
told people to inject bleach so i think
we've got a clip and
oh let's roll this clip really quickly
and then fact check again the promo code
is crowder
town hall 20 off for 24 hours do we have
that clip token allen
let's run it
that's the beginning of the clip no no
that's actually what he did things like
you know everything from
as crazy stuff he's walking away from
now inject bleach in your arm and
that's going to work i'm not being a bit
i'm not being facetious though
he's actually said these things oh there
we go
this is this is from politifact oh my
gosh and you know they really wanted
that to be true here's the thing with
biden has gone on so unchecked which by
the way drink every time biden lies
that's part of the drinking game hit
that thing there
um biden has got gotten by
so for so long without any
accountability
that he just lies without any
ramification and he just
he just leans into it too much like if
he would have just said that donald
trump implied
one could maybe use bleach or
disinfectants but instead he said donald
trump said that you could take a belt or
surgical tubing
heat up the bleach in a spoon with a
torch lighter and inject it straight
into your arm like he got specific
in his life exactly well but the media
carries his water somebody's going to
call him on it and then he said i'm not
lying about this right
i'm not lying right now but let me give
you a very specific scenario that even
politifact who really wants to support
me is going to say
[ __ ] you took this transcript the way
that he went on that when he starts to
say well you know i'm being facetious
you could you could hear his like
you know handlers being like okay great
you just walked us out of defamation
but it's not facetious and they're like
it looks like they're gonna come back
here soon is there anything else that we
missed or you know what uh
reg the bandit um we can come back to
you keep compiling those clips everyone
watching it's crowder
town hall that's a discount code
drinking game rules and of course we
have a costume contest
after this um it's just a lot going on
two string
two streams on one stream so much going
on the other two streams
on this one stream you don't cross
streams we do crosstalk
that's a different thank you very much
um we're a hard-working middle-class
family of four
my husband and i are both self-employed
and we have to get our own individual
health care
as you know health care costs have gone
up considerably
over the decades and you have originally
to make health care costs affordable for
americans
well the good thing is you're speaking
to the first president modern history
who lowered the cost of drug trafficking
which was the worst part of obamacare
and now you could actually say it's not
obamacare because that's how big it was
where you had to pay a fortune for the
privilege of not having to pay for
bad health insurance so we got rid of
that that was a big big thing
and by doing that and we will always
have by way we're always
protecting people with pre-existing
conditions and i can't say that more
strongly
but we've been able to bring health care
costs way down
now i took over obamacare got rid of the
individual mandate
made it good manage it much better
remember they had the five billion
dollar
uh website disaster and all of them oh
yeah
yeah we'd like to terminate it
and we want gabriel
that's a much better health care and
that's where we're aiming
and if we can do that and we have a very
good chance of doing it
but we've also brought down the price of
obamacare
from with obamacare it basically is
never going to be great and i want to
give great
healthcare and it roses americans by 105
more than that on average in 39 states
before 2017.
and sorry deductibles went up over 212
by 2018. so yeah which includes the
protections for pre-existing conditions
right now trying to get rid of that
protection in order to replace it with a
much better health care at a much lower
price
you have a baby
and i mean maybe i changed the party a
lot over the last three years
but we will protect people with
pre-existing conditions
and savannah what i want to do get rid
of the terrible obamacare i've already
done it to a large extent because as you
know the
the individual mandate is gone that was
the worst
appeal but you haven't replaced now
you've been in office almost four years
you had both houses of congress senate
and and house
in republican hands and there is not a
replacement yet that's right i'm sorry
but don't paint your nails
i said what did we do we got rid of the
individual this is the man's downhill
always repeal and replace
go paint your nails and perfume your
i want it very simple i'm going to put
it very simple we would like to
terminate it and we would like to
replace it with something that's much
less expensive
and much better we will always protect
people with pre-existing conditions
in november
because we took it apart we are running
the remnants of whatever is left
much better than the previous
administration which rented very badly
but we'd like to have new health care
much better and much less expensive
let me get to question number five and
you'll like this he's stuck in traffic
his name is
joe white he is registered as a democrat
now we're in october and it's still not
passed why not use your office to make
the second stimulus
targeted emergency relief package to
help americans weather the panthers i've
actually passed three packages but when
we're
on the most recent one is 1.8 trillion
that democrats have denied by the way
just because they didn't include a
bailout for the postal service
effectively but what you know
she couldn't care less about our people
and we should have a stimulus
white supremacy what did you mean by
that
she's talking to a black guy
the fact is she's wrong because people
know she's in our way
she's not approving it she doesn't
appreciate our people and she doesn't
approve
appreciate it all our workers we're
talking about nodding model in the back
man she's on all the points
oh it's
you one day tweeted no more negotiations
until
election until after election day i'm
and i think walking away couple of days
you said maybe we can do something
targeted
then you said i want a big big bill but
then senate republicans said
no we're not for that so you're the big
deal maker how come this is so how you
yourself this is how you negotiate
1.8 trillion right now democrats just
have to say yes okay
that's savannah the people is there is
there any accountability for nancy
pelosi
or because she's a woman do you just
picture a man and remove all reason and
accountability
is there nothing at the feet for nancy
pelosi who by the way is so used to
softballs and when wolf blitzer said why
don't you just say yes to the deal
and so did andrew yang she accused wolf
blitzer and andrew yang of carrying the
republican party's water
can you imagine if nancy pelosi had to
deal with the [ __ ] that donald trump
does day in and day out when wolf
blitzer just said
yeah you won a 2.2 one point it truly is
a pretty good deal she's like
reagan nancy and i through my
representatives or directly i don't care
if we agree to something the republicans
will agree to it
okay our next question comes from oh
this is interesting she voted for
clinton in 2016.
recently from democrat to independent
she says she's truly undecided her name
is becky lightman
hello becky what's your question how are
you i'm great
how are you so
corporate tax rates are a hot button
issue and
you have cut corporate tax rates and
your opponent joe biden is planning to
raise them a lot of americans think that
corporations
don't pay their share of taxes and want
to see those tax rates
increase what do you say to those
americans to
maybe tell them why you want the
corporate tax rate lower
and wider helps them it's a great
question we've created more jobs
than this country has ever created we're
up to 160 million jobs we were never
even close to that number
we were just hitting 160 million jobs
companies are pouring into our nation
because of the tax rate and if biden
comes in and raises taxes on everybody
including middle income taxes which he
wants to do
you will blow this thing and you'll end
up with a depression the likes of which
you've never had that's what's going to
happen
we have something that's really good the
reason we're coming back when you look
at the norwegian country the
scandinavian model
they have lower corporate taxes they
have
effectively and actually the poor pay a
higher percentage of taxes because of
the vat taxes that you see there's a
much higher sales tax on everything
in the scandinavian countries that's
what the prime minister of denmark said
when he was like hey bernie
shut up shut up bernie sanders stop
calling us a socialist country we're a
free-market economy
and you are a whole of an ass and so
they actually have higher value-added
taxes and they have lower corporate
taxes
than the united states that's something
people understand yeah even in europe
we're socialists we're not morons
but like we want to scare out the
business away but you want some altar
goes to the cayman islands or panama
you're already tarted we can't let that
happen on the subject
of taxes as you know the new york times
has obtained it says
years of your tax returns among other
things it says that you have debts of
approximately 421 million dollars that
you have personally
guaranteed and that will come due in the
next four years how much debt did you
have your democratic
what they did is illegal number one also
the numbers
number one the numbers they released and
just so you understand when you have
a lot of real estate have real estate
but twitter's still letting people
forward that around
right down the road doraleous true big
stuff great stuff how was that
i'm very under when i decided you know
very
under levered fortunately but i'm very
under levered
i have a very very small percentage of
debt compared
in fact some of it i did as favors the
institutions that wanted to loan me
money
400 million dollars compared to the
assets that i have
all of these great properties all over
the world and frankly
the bank of america building in san
francisco i don't love what's happening
to san francisco
isn't that my biggest office buildings
but are you are you are you confirming
that yes you do owe
some 400 million what i'm saying is that
it's a tiny percentage of my net worth
and you'll see that soon because i know
is watching
town hall keep an eye out for whether
they ask him about any finances
particularly involving one hunter biden
or property that may be paid for by
other people
i just want to see if he's getting the
same treatment or if they're just
handing him levodopa between commercials
and injecting him with stimulants
you know what's funny is they go uh sir
you owe 400 000
i see to uh bank of america when is that
going to come to uh i actually own a
house that's a mortgage
for a house well so that doesn't really
matter a thousand dollars
400 million dollars to the bank of no
upper limb
by the way it's a high interest load
small amount of money i want to say they
don't understand how this works like how
finance works
if you dive into it he's under leverage
he'll walk away with hundreds of
millions of dollars if he refinances in
a couple of years
he will do very well under levered yeah
i am extremely
under level here's the thing by just
releasing
the same thing it's the same thing first
just because
it turned out that i am excuse me
[Music]
so that was solved that's good i am
underrated no person by the way
your questions costume contest winner so
please do consider joining up at
lottothecutter.com
wonderful lady you can just fill around
these administrations they treat me very
badly
we're under it's very routine in many
ways but we're under audit they like to
change the game
change the rules do everything you saw
what they did with the tea party people
you saw what they did with the religion
clear there is no law or rule that
prohibits you from releasing your tax
returns
there's no law rule intelligence and
having lawyers it's got to be a thug
common sense and as soon as we come to a
conclusion i will release them and very
quickly
but if you go to you ask
don't worry it talks about the income
which is rather massive
it talks about all of the properties
they have them listed
you can never learn more but you know
what happened people went there all the
reporters went there was like a feeding
frenzy now you're making it worse
originally when i filed it
and i filed it every year i updated it
every year my son is here
they run the company i don't run the
company
in taxes in
women in tight white tops with large
breasts behind donald trump
oh wow they did it he was like
no one's gonna pay no
but their numbers were wrong but let me
tell you what else
uh i don't owe money to any of these
sinister
people this has been going on for years
now russia russia russia
turned out to be a hoax and it turned
out to be that hillary clinton and the
democrats
were dealing with russia not me oh yeah
it's a whole hoax
so i would not mind at all saying who is
when i go into whole foods and whack the
watermelons to see which ones are right
oh look at this guy he's so rude he says
thank you to the lady who's been
interrogating it laughing now and you're
seeing it shake listen i'm sorry
i don't mean women just so you know
that's what if you're wearing a mask and
you've got very large
uh and i mean this isn't it wonderful
there's nothing wrong with it
fantastic good for you you're a woman
here you roar but i'm going to go
look at them i'm going to be thinking
about that well and they're they're kind
of showing them off too they're ringing
they're not showing them off
they're wearing matter it's not their
fault
that they are very well endowed good for
you saying that good for you
the both of you yeah it's gerald
it's crowder town hall 20 off we can
bring up the drinking game rules here
really quickly so people can see them
can you recite them out loud their audio
aid
yeah so if trump gets a leading question
or an unfair question drops of
thug life moment says china or fake news
you finish your drink if trump mentions
hunter biden
and then if biden gets a softball
question has a dimension moment or
talks tough and says come on and then
you will hear this
ding and now it is time for us to
transfer over
to the bidentown all you ready doc go
okay all right that's a really oh
it's amazing that car didn't catch on
more reg the bandit everyone who's
working it louder with crowder
by the way if people are watching and
people work remotely every single one of
you better be watching the biden town
hall stream right now
uh reg the bandit what do we have what's
going on with biden
well we had some uh discussion of
biden's
past legislation on crime and so i think
we have a clip of him
discussing his crime bill and then a
little fact check of that
okay really quick before that did they
ask him about his finances at all uh
biden do they ask him about the finances
and hunter or anything like that yet
uh is that supposed to be a joke or okay
the silliest thing about me talking to a
man in a pair of briefs that were cut
into a raccoon
is if the media was doing their job okay
let's go
to the clip right now about uh joe
biden's racist criminal
uh legislation history what's your view
on the crime bill
that you wrote in 1994 which showed
prejudice against minorities
where do you stand today well first of
all things have changed drastically that
crime bill went and voted
the black caucus voted for it every
black mayor supported it
across the board then then they moved
into my neighborhood damn it
then they all moved into my neighborhood
and i was getting out i was in chevy
chase out there and they were leaving
they were leaving baltimore they changed
things
i want them to do well i don't want to
have to look at them in my cul-de-sac
uh i couldn't see what that is to have a
really small monitor tonight uh reg the
bandits uh
is that true yeah so from
factcheck.org we have a little context
there that he's spinning the facts
initially it was sort of embarrassing
because only
uh well 10 of the 38 bike democrats
actually voted against him when it came
to the crime field and so
it hung it up on a procedural motion and
then clinton
actually had to go meet with those guys
and convince them to vote for it so it
wasn't really smooth sailing it wasn't
just that everyone supported it
uh he had to get clinton in there to
sort of clean things up
so joseph biden was so unlikable
that clinton went in to do his bidding
and it worked uh is there anything else
that we've missed because i know they're
going to come back here soon or is that
the main
main gist of it i think that's the main
point i think we're switching over to
the supreme court
uh here so there should be some goods oh
that'll be interesting
uh keep us abreast we're about to go
back to the donald trump quick let's go
back and trump town hall
thank you again for being here we've got
another voter
adam sugar he voted for clinton in 2016.
he's adam shucker
he hardly knew him supporting biden adam
take it away
thank you savannah thank you mr
president thank you four years ago
senate leadership
said it was inappropriate to push
through a nominee in an election year oh
boy
yet they fast-tracked your nominee for
the supreme court just today
bryan the question i have for you is how
do you
what do you say to the voter that thinks
it's hypocritical to act in that manner
and that they can't trust republicans
watch our
reasons and uh
[Laughter]
because i had great respect for justice
ginsburg but
a vacancy happened to come up and we
picked somebody that's outstanding she
has been
an absolute star happy to come up here
plenty of time i mean there's plenty of
time we're going to do it before the
election but we also have much time
after the election but there's no reason
to wait
because it's almost unanimous it seems
to me certainly within the republican
party and frankly most of the democrats
within closed rooms i guarantee you that
this is an outstanding
person and they wouldn't be using right
and you know they would because they're
hypocrites on the other foot
if they had this they would do it one
hundred percent
there's been 29 times when this has
happened all 29 times
a president has done exactly that look
at that black [ __ ] nodding
in 2016. every time the wonderful
wonderful black lady beautiful
you said i think the senate should wait
until the next president and let the
president
pick now that was eight months before
the election
this is three weeks before the election
so you you have changed your position on
this i have a lot of respect for judge
garland i want to tell you that
but i'll tell you the whole ball game
changed
when i saw the way they treated justice
kavanaugh
i have never second nodding model i'm
not just talking about supreme court
i have never seen a human being treated
so badly with false accusations and
everything else
i have never seen anything like it and
you know what the truth is savannah like
it or not
the ball game changed a lot there has
never been anybody treated simply
[Applause]
dangle my balls on the forehead of every
last democrat
the ball game changed any challenges
come up in connection
with the election do you expect her to
rule
uh i think she'll hurt her i don't think
she has any conflict at all
you know a supreme court judge does not
have i mean they can make their own
decision
uh the the and they actually have
additional power to make that decision
uh
oh do you see that totally up to her one
tick behind her i would think that she
would
by the way isn't it again any conflict
whatsoever
we have an election coming up i think
it's the most important election in the
history of our country
if for any chance does it ever get to
the supreme court
i would think that she would rule one
way or the other i would think so but
for you you think she would rule for you
i have no idea i mean of course
one way or the other but in the law we
call that objection asked and answered
yeah i never talked about it
i didn't talk about any of the obvious
things that you could talk about trump
and i think a lot of people they were
trying to they were trying to pin her on
that trying to get her on
the donald
they say it's better not to talk so i
talked to her about
life i talked to her about the fact
would you like to do this are you
willing to do this because it's a
tremendous burden
the answer was yes she is unbelievably
well qualified
but i never spoke to her about these
various questions let's get our next
voter
she said to you mr president 2016 she's
a registered republican
her name is mariah green
[Music]
thank you good evening mr president i'm
honored to be with you
you here tonight uh sir so thank you
i'm a pro-life millennial and my
question for you today better looking
than that
if roe v wade is ultimately overturned
in the future
what protections would be put in place
or kept for where the mother's life is
in jeopardy in relation to high-risk
pregnancies well again i'm not
ruling in this and roe v wade is
something that a lot of people would say
obviously you're going to speak to
somebody i
also two other great justices
justice gorsuch and justice kavanaugh i
never spoke to them about roe v
wade i never spoke to them about
election laws i never spoke to him about
anything
and i've done the right thing from a
moral standpoint i don't even know from
a legal standpoint but it was the right
thing
[Music]
i think depending on what happens with
roe v wade i think that perhaps it could
get sent down to the states that's
exactly what this is
completely overturned it just punts it
back to the states that's
all it does power in the first place
anyway it would be inappropriate to talk
to about it
and some people would say you can talk
to about it i just think it would be
appropriate
up until nine months as you saw in our
hidden camera abortion video sometimes
one day or virginia
up until after birth right shouldn't
texas be able to
cut down shouldn't texas you'll say okay
you know what no abortion here you want
one go to the state where they uh you
know i'll let you have it up until uh
the baby's first word for a long time
make a decision and that's why i chose
her i think that she's going to make a
great decision i did not tell her what
decision to make
and i think it would be inappropriate to
say right now because i don't want to do
anything to influence her
i want her to get approved and then i
want her to go by the law
by the way i know she's going to make it
to his right
left doesn't like this you can see her
twiddling her thumbs
[Music]
we'll see what happens all right we have
another question
she is undecided she said she's leaning
to buy anything
they should probably matter in the womb
hi cindy what's your question good
evening good evening mr president thank
you very much
as the mother of a young male of color
i have raised him to respect authority
not only because it's the right thing to
do
but also out of fear that he may face
profiling
or be considered a criminal as an
educator
i've also had similar conversations with
my high school students
mr president what will you and your
administration do
to better prepare our law enforcement
officers to work in collaboration with
the communities that they serve
and also to protect the lives beyond the
fact that there are actually more
minorities in the police force than the
general population do you mean that what
do you want to do
that's a good question you don't like
that question no everything that you saw
over the summer and it was a terrible
thing
a terrible thing to watch we were very
strongly we have a senator named
tim scott from south carolina he came up
with a bill that should have been
approved that was great
it was a bill that was strong in terms
of law enforcement and strong in terms
of
enforcing the proper thing and doing the
proper thing by law enforcement
and the democrats just wouldn't go for
it they wouldn't go for it at all and i
don't know why
because it was getting rid of a great
bill but i do have to say this
it's really a nancy's and some people
don't like it when i say it but a lot of
people agree
i have done more for the
african-american community than any
president criminal justice reform
prison reform historically black
colleges and universities i got them
funded they were in a year oh yeah
they could have been put out of business
they would have said i'm sorry we're not
going to fund you i got them 10-year
funding and financing and more than they
even asked for i became very friendly
with a lot of the heads
but we've done more and of course
opportunity zones
but criminal justice reform everybody
said it could it could not be done
president obama and biden never even
tried to do it they never even tried
but i say that and i say it often i'll
say it loud and i'm very proud of it
with the african-american community i'm
very proud of it
yes and you know someone right now nbc
news is going okay cut the camera too
camera through camera two there's a
black black no back no blacks no more
blacks
so they've moved
surveys show that most
americans and the majority of
republicans
support the dreamers program
so my question for you mr president is
if you are elected to a second term
do you expect to pursue
your previous efforts to cut
the daca program why or why not
and the daca daca is somewhat different
than dreamers you understand that and
you understand it better than anybody
probably in this room
where do you come from by the way
originally my grandparents were from
russia
and poland that's very good okay awkward
so i respect you we are going to take
care of daca
we're going to take care of dreamers i
know usually it's working right now
we're negotiating different aspects of
immigration
and immigration law we've built now
over 400 miles of border wall southern
border
mexico is working very closely with us
we have the strongest border we've ever
had
we want people to come into our country
they have to come in legally but we are
working very hard
on the daca program and you will be i
think
very happy over the course of the next
year thank you because i feel the same
way as you do about it thank you mr
president that was a great answer
and in fact the daca recipients now have
to renew every year
as opposed to every two years so in fact
was down at the mexico border because he
had to get renewed for three years you
know we've had to get bringing in
somebody else's managed business here
who was incredibly skilled
it was he had to jump through hoops and
he needed to jump through hoops just to
get renewed
and he did it himself for help he told
me can i go down
can i go down to the border i said
absolutely
this is something that all legal
immigrants have to do
it's not because you're brown you
haven't heard any complaints about that
but what happened is savannah was sold
on the break to stop interrupting they
have to be
yes she has been well more behaved since
well at least july when you told me
it's very happy that the fact is we got
rid of catch and release which is a
disaster
you know you catch somebody they could
be a murderer they could be a rapist and
we're supposed to release them
into our country these are the laws that
i inherited we ended that program
that is absolutely true here's the deal
when people talk about
not deporting right children who were
born to illegal immigrant parents
because they didn't do anything wrong
okay fine
but would you deport all felons who are
here illegally in our prisons
let's start no nancy pelosi refuses san
francisco refuses sanctuary cities
refused so let's not act
it's like with abortion and say what
about rape or incest okay if we allow
rape incest would you get rid of all the
other abortions
then don't present that argument it's
not about children
it's about votes why they should give
you a second chance and how you might
improve in a second term
30 seconds what would you say to them
because the only leading questions
assuming you need the strongest economy
in the world we closed it up
we are coming around the corner
our economy is strong we are at 11
with jobs like we've never been before
we've rebuilt our military
we've rebuilt our borders we had no
borders we had known nothing
we've rebuilt so much we've given you
the greatest tax cut in the history of
our country
greatest regulation cut equally as
important
and we created new levels of jobs that
nobody thought was possible
and next year is going to be better than
ever before
i got a wrap from wow
wow
on she's cheering for president donald
trump all right uh i hate to be a step
down i hate to be a buzzkill but uh
because we wanted you to be able to
uh enjoy both streams and now there's
another half hour
to the riddled dementia at giant
advertisement you talk about big pharma
this is one big glorified
billboard for levodopa
biden and by the way really quickly i
just want to let you guys know of course
this
uh is sponsored today uh by black rifle
coffee
wonderful coffee i drink it every day
except for right now because of my
stomach
yes i started drinking coffee girl girl
gurgle
but blackriflecoffee.com crowder you get
20 off your first order and uh
veteran owned veteran operated but their
coffee is fresh roasted
fantastic stuff awesome it's just better
coffee and you're not supporting people
who hate your country
like this guy and oh my gosh what is she
not totally enough for the turtles club
let's go to the uh smells like people i
think
away from fossil fuels
that are not harmful to human health and
the environment are you planning for
southwest pennsylvania
and the nation why is she asking a
question did some kids throw a ball into
your lot where the mastiff wouldn't let
him retrieve it
frackie i think you have to make sure
that's like a more
it's like a tracy morgan character yeah
i mean
i wanna know why you sound like you had
your [ __ ]
mind what does a ghetto mating call look
like very well number one
no further questions you crazy ass it's
the future
fastest growing energy source in the
world right now
because i'm going to say something
that's going to sound self-serving but i
managed to
provide and i was able to invest
billions of dollars into
bringing the recovery that's right
i don't think she likes biden so now
women's soldiers
and it has great great promise
we just went from the trump town hall
okay we just went from the trump town
hall
with savannah guthrie am i pronouncing
that savannah guthrie who's married
to a democratic communications
consultant to a guy who
actually worked as a communications
director for the clintons
wow and they want us to think that
they're objective it's unbiased
unbiased i do let's say you've got a
point trump went into the lion's den
oh yeah of course when i heard that it
was savannah guthrie i thought to myself
man cojones on that i mean you knew it
wasn't gonna be
straight shooting yeah i think he did
pretty well i think he actually did
pretty well
but i want to compare it we're here with
biden i know reg the bandit will have
some fact checks for what we missed but
right now he's talking about the
recovery act and solar and wind which of
course
we know sucks find the right technology
some guys looks like he's a needlepoint
he has to be able to if we can carbon
capture
and i think we're going to be able to
move in a direction where by the year
2035
we'll be able to have net zero
emissions of carbon from the creation of
energy energy creation what that's so we
can move it by uh
my question was about pluto and [ __ ] the
president thinks
of uh because you know how bad planets
are bernie ball's
gas jobs i think you misread my inquiry
you'll be able to see now
as i started to say before
and what we have to do is focus on the
transmission i think she's
also getting bored slowly
okay so what you're saying is you
[ __ ]
you know what he said that has not yet
met a lot of people solar wind compared
to germany we can fact-check this
compared germany who went with with uh
renewable energy which included solar
and wind and they shunned nuclear
compare them with france
france actually reduced their carbon
emissions and france
is more effective and pay a lower net
energy cost and by the way they have
fewer deaths per kilowatt hour which is
how it's
actually measured versus germany who
actually increased their carbon
emissions during that same time but what
happened to all the solar and wind well
what happens is you don't have a power
grid that could actually maintain that
that can actually
hold the power can reserve the power and
so they would have brown outs
and then they'd have power surpluses
which they would have to sell at net
negatives when they had brown outs guess
what they have to go back to
coal because they don't have the same
kind of fracking we have here in the
united states
also there are still a few nazis working
in there
you want to see what his plan looks like
california hold on i want to see if he
goes in hard on biden like god
buys your denial let me go to heart
makers local 154 sean stephanie
was quoting the new york times today
saying you can't have it both ways
it says you can't meet your goal to end
fossil fuels without ending fracking
what do you say to people like sean who
doubt your denial because they think
you you want to keep that promise makers
overwhelm me endorse me okay
so the boilermakers unions endorsed me
because i sat down with them
in a great detail
what i would do is i would stop making i
would stop the
giving tax breaks subsidizing
oil that's what's waiting for jesus to
subsidize oil any longer
number one we should stop that and save
billions of dollars over time
what i would also do with your
subsidized there's no wind and solar
interference doesn't work
subsidizing by the way oil industries by
2030
we're going to be carbon free not
possible so you forward or against it
you say you're not
foreign
my deal is a crucial framework but not
the new green deal the new green deal
calls for elimination of green new deal
all non-renewable energy by 2030. you
can't get there
you're going to need to be able to
transition george to be able to
transition to get to the place
why do we need to transform new
technologies that allow us to do things
that george
get us to a place where we get to net
zero emission including in agriculture
i've laid out a detailed plan
we should be taking an answer on
fracking
by the way how do you think you get the
net zero carbon emissions
the methane and use it as fertilizer and
make a lot of money doing it
for example right now down in and people
when i say that they wonder what i'm
talking about
the biggest carbon sink in the world is
the amazon
more carbon absorbed from the air back
to the diminishing
global warming in the amazon then all
the carbon emitted on a year but
fracking
that's a good thing in the amazon
unfortunately they also don't have
anything to hold their tickets use our
images
as well providing for true electric
vehicles
electric vehicles
and people who've never seen abroad and
actually joe biden.com does say
joe biden believes that the green new
deal is a crucial framework for meeting
the climate changes we face
challenges joe um did they just turn the
music on
he's still talking look at that and by
the way he's talking to nobody
he's like huh hold on who's the patron
saint
of uh stopping me from talking out of my
ass because i forgot my rosary which i
only use
out of political opportunism uh really
quickly before we
we go into this uh reg the bandit what
did we miss from the biden town hall
before we switched over
so there are a couple things of note on
the
supreme court question biden actually
said and and this
almost we don't even have to run a clip
it's so uh false
he said that he thought it was in by
implication it was
unconstitutional to nominate a new
justice before the election he said his
reading of the constitution
his reading says that by information you
have to wait and so yeah you know he
talked about how he's taught
constitutional law and things well his
version of the constitution says if you
fart in your hand you can throw it
across the room
oh next bit he also mentioned that
by the way uh did he happen to mention
something known as the um um
uh biden rule because you know that it's
named after him and it says that you can
do this if you control the senate and
the white house i'm sorry
it's his rule not ours well he doesn't
know that not anymore
all right what else do we have of note
there uh reg the bandit
he did mention that he would not tonight
but at some point give an answer on
court packing
and november 4th i think we also have a
clip of his
uh he has some ideas on how to perform
uh policing
so i think we do have a clip of that all
right let's go to the clip of how biden
would do
policing you're watching the crowder
town hall the promo code is crowder town
hall at lightwood.com
mug club and uh you can use the hashtag
we'll be uh announcing a costume contest
winner let's go to his answer on
policing
we can do this you can ban choke holes
you can but
but beyond that you have to teach people
how to de-escalate circumstances
de-escalate so instead of anybody coming
at you the first thing you do is shoot
the kill
you shoot him in a leg he's still
walking at us oh my god
[Applause]
no no no no no no no miss miss miss miss
got
[Music]
[Music]
he's trying to tase him now by the way
bad idea wow
wow in most cases this cops throat gets
cut should have shot him in the leg
i'm willing to bet that guy's in pcp or
something yeah by the way people wonder
why the democrats why
they're always advised by uh consultants
by people who actually
are campaign managers to avoid the gun
issue because any person who's ever
taken
a concealed carry course or you
obviously you're a competitive shooter
anyone who's ever taken a basic gun
safety course let alone concealed safe
concealed carry course is they tell you
listen if you're gonna have to aim your
gun you have first off don't take it out
unless you're okay with the potential
of destroying that target and aim for
chest center mass because you miss most
of the time the first thing to tell you
is
it's a myth this idea in the movies that
you can aim for the legs or shoot a gun
out of your hand
it's a total myth but biden repeats it
because he's never learned anything
about guns he's out of touch
with a huge portion of the american
populace we challenged him
nobody said hey isn't it pretty hard to
shoot somebody in the leg when you're
like
not only that i mean there's a couple
reasons one smaller target two
even if you do that the the kind of
crippling injury that happens is
you're essentially saying oh i'd like to
just maim them instead right
when you're shooting at concrete bullets
do actually skip there's the opportunity
of shooting at a certain angle that is
almost guaranteed to go past
and then go into a different target
you're not just shooting this person to
protect yourself
but you're shooting in a controlled way
look at that look at the brianna taylor
situation
the who are just randomly shooting and
you're shooting at a small target or
you're shooting indiscriminately
you put other people in danger so
there's exactly there's a lot of
different reasons keep in mind this is
the guy who also said just take a double
bell shotgun and fire it
into the air yeah
come back down what were you about to
say their audio i was just gonna say we
do have a relevant chat
uh from ben he says question for reg the
bandit how many republicans have asked
biden questions so far he's watching the
biden because i
think only one only one has any trump
anything right hey reg's the bandit do
you think you could check that for us
and get back to us uh because we have to
go to
biden uh i would say speaking out his
ass but um
speaking out his ass if he were a cone
head because i don't have acids let's go
back
get back to us on that reg with a count
trivia
welcome to pennsylvania mr vice
president is the old who wants to be a
millionaire
peace is breaking out all over the world
our troops are coming home
serbia is talking to kosovo and the
arabs
and israelis are talking peace which i
believe is a modern day miracle what's
going on
does president trump's foreign policy
deserve some credit a little
but not a whole lot we find ourselves in
a position where we're
more isolated in the world than we've
ever been our allies
are are paying more into nato than they
ever have and israel just had the
biggest peace treaty that's been signed
in modern
history closer to having enough nuclear
material to build a
a bomb north korea has more bombs i'm
sorry did you say iran
sir we found out yeah sorry you had
yourself
saying they can't count on us we're in a
situation as well where
in the far east we find ourselves in in
the
priest from simon where we're isolated
as well
you have japan and uh and and
south korea at odds with another china
is making moves so
did you stay at odds with uh others
dementia moments because he's not making
sense then we've been i do compliment
the president
on the deal with uh with
israel recently um but uh you know uh
deals you had eight years and did
nothing you're only pissed off you
trusted around the world did you say 48
years
17 48 years to do something
who's a better leader and the president
someone bring me
both the national survey international
survey
both behind putin as well as um
interesting you bring up who and look
what putin's doing hey has he had an
answer for anything with his son
american interesting
military's heads in afghanistan they
have more people
there internationally uh ronald reagan
also winston churchill those guys were
not liked by other countries but guess
what it's not a popularity
and nato is on the risk of money talk
crack nato
because they don't doubt they doubt our
budget whether they're there
in everything money talks nato poland
to hungary and the rise of totalitarian
regimes in the world and as well as this
president embraces all the thugs in the
world
i mean he's best friends but you embrace
the thugs in america
as well as the uh uh
so i i would respectfully suggest no
there is no plan well the plan is
resulted in
no major new wards the only modern
american president to ever do that you
guys had more on
man's drone strikes than anyone in
history so you know listen you guys
sucked on this front
just call it a loss take the size of our
power and most people if you were to
actually pull people on individual
issues what do you think about the
israel uh
israeli peace treaty right away people
would if you pull people on individual
issues
donald trump would come out on top in
those individual issues particularly on
issues of national security
and foreign policy it wouldn't even be
close the problem is
they don't do that because the people
running interference are the former
democrat white house communications
director
george stephen and then one who's
married
to somebody who's the poor man
stephanopoulos savannah guthrie these
are the people in charge of the town
halls tonight
let's see if he looks look do you notice
right away there's another question no
fact check
of joe biden nothing no fact check at
all compared to savannah who's like yeah
but she had the covet though
yeah but she didn't wear a mask of two
girls
eight and 10. my youngest daughter is
transgender
the trump administration has attacked
the rights of transgender people
banning them from military side your
gender and sex how can you decide your
sex and your driver's license
before you even have the ability to uh
climax sexually eight years old
eight years old you can decide to cause
reproductive harm
the agenda will make sexual decisions on
anything else but you're going to make a
decision that permanently alters your
sex life sorry let's go ahead let's
listen to this protected
under u.s law i will flat out just
change the law
every eliminate those executive orders
number one
you may recall i'm the guy who said uh i
was raised by a man
who uh i remember that was that was
straight talked off right drink
training high school educational
was a really decent guy and i was being
dropped off to
get an application in the center of our
city wilmington delaware
a corporate capital of the world at the
time and these two men i'm
getting out to get a an application to
be a lifeguard in the african-american
community because there was a big
swimming pool complex
and uh and was the transgender and the
african-american swingers
wow i'm getting out of the car my dad
my dad looked at me said joey it's
simple they love each other
the idea that an eight-year-old child or
a ten-year-old child decides
you know i decided i want to be
transgender that's what i thought well
you just decided sexual orientation i
won't say preference because apparently
it's offensive now to uh
a merriam-webster i believe actually
changed their dictionary too quickly
categorized sexual preference as
offensive as a derogatory term
you just mentioned two blade two gay
black men
and then transition to trend do you have
any idea what they would do if donald
trump equated the two well do you think
they'll hang him on
decide he wants to be transgender yeah
right because you're born with it
it's immutable it's immutable according
to youtube that's why i was allowed to
laugh
at a transgender individual who
committed physical assault with a fidget
spinner
remember literally i could not laugh
because it was immutable
that was youtube's terminology and the
terminology of hirono
and he just said choose to be
transgender you don't choose something
that's immutable
he was the guy who got by the way i
agree with you
can i ask a question for chat wow look
no nothing nothing no just actually
right the commercials like let me give
you a wide open lane here
and uh we'll go to a commercial yeah
your question for chat they're happy all
right so
i'm really i'm really interested in this
i've talked with a lot of folks recently
and they are concerned about their
family and i don't just mean
their kids or their spouse but they're
concerned about their parents they're
concerned about their extended family
and what i want to see in the chat is of
all the different
crazy dangerous and moral positions yeah
that
biden has actually talked about because
we know a few of them he just won't even
answer
right but the ones he's talked about
what makes you most concerned for your
family
and why you know what are the what is
the issue that is most concerning to you
and what are you most concerned about
when biden if he were to get another
trick question if you have an
eight-year-old who you allow to chop off
their [ __ ]
yeah you can't choose that one because
that's too obvious okay you can't use
that one
obviously i think it was girl to go well
i don't care
i don't care you don't allow
eight-year-olds
to undergo hormone blockers just like
you don't allow eight-year-olds to wipe
their boogers under the couch i know
because my dad spanked me and i deserved
it
i thought no one would notice that that
was my booger nook
that's the true story that's disgusting
can we at least
hand the god hand to the place that joe
biden keeps looking up to yeah
i had a booger nook i remember what i
remember what it looked like
it's very different uh reg the bandit
what else you said there were some other
things that
had been going on here that we missed oh
no wait wait that's right
the republican number was the number we
were looking for how many yes the
questions i don't know if you're able to
find that
yeah so i've been trying to keep track i
think he had one question
from a republican who voted for john
kasich
that does that count which i don't know
if that counts yeah it was john kasich
it was
i want to know as i wasn't going to take
the lowest road to the highest office
in the land why does everyone hate me
take any road to the highest office and
then joe biden said cause you're an
[ __ ] man
all right uh like give me more uh
answers there was one other guy i don't
want to hear from you i want to hear
from raj abandoned he's the smart one
oh well i was going to say there was one
voter who said she voted for trump
and then she was now undecided
and so yeah i i me maybe
a soft two questions from republicans oh
man
as opposed to the hard every single
question from savannah guthrie yeah
that's what i was going to say i was
like how many times did uh george
jump in there interrupt yell name call
question uh ask leading questions did he
ever did because we missed it we were
watching donald trump during that time
was george stephanopoulos was he
grilling
joe biden asking for follow-ups at all
no he was quite the sweetie pie
positive and you know very happy okay
well
uh also did they place bosomy women in
white sweaters behind
joe biden because i don't know if you
were able to see but that's what they
were doing with the trump town hall
yeah no we he he had kind of an open
stage there right they made a big show
of you know it wasn't six feet it was
like 60 feet in between him and stephan
so yeah well so opposed to donald trump
they had open blouses
biden goes for like the 10 to 12 year
old girls they were in the green room
for him to smell before coming out yeah
exactly he's fine they're like mr biden
would you like a diffuser with essential
oils that'll actually uh peppermint is
awakening do you have
seven oh is that i'm not familiar is
that a blend seven-year-old
it's just seven-year-old uh susie
can you put that in the uh in the uh
what's the name of that uh
the the mormon essential oil company oh
i don't know ah someone living here yeah
can you put that
i'm a big fan of it i was a big fan of
young living until i found out what it
was all about
that's false advertising they sell oils
who knew
they're the company for me young living
party
it was incredibly disappointing man
he was fine when they were bpa i called
epstein and said don't go
it's a scam but that is plain and all
that man
young living's a scam
he just said when they went kid free
that's that's why it's so sad
all right let's see good evening
um you say that you committed to
entering this race after the events
of charlottesville in 2017.
i assume that that feeling that prompted
you to run will not go away once the
results are determined
so i have to find people right if you
lose
noise how will you use your platform to
urge president donald trump and those
rallying behind him
towards the ideals of a more perfect
union well i got plans for a swimming
record
honest with you um i don't know
i think that's very hard he is not
things have not led themselves to him uh
learning from what's happened what's
gone before
uh what often instead of what what did
you just say
dude you just witnessed it it's the only
president
if there isn't something from george
stephanopoulos right now follow him
uh vice president binding so but what i
care to make sense
then you know this is a shame drink
dementia moment to university
sorry pardon my language and making the
case the black guys like
the top biden institute at the
university of delaware focusing on
on these same issues relating to what
constitutes
decency and honor in this country uh
yeah son's smoking crack and introducing
you to you
radiant diplomats substantiated
well we just had giuliani on the show
delaware i'm a i can't believe you
showed up
this is a laptop and it's just riddled
with crack okay and surprisingly enough
stephen cox
i'm no great shakespeare this question
asker guy is like
uh he's not like yeah that's about what
i'm figuring
you crazy as hell there's there's
[Music]
or i'm elected president it is a major
going to the old folks
element of everything that i'm about
you're going to wear because
governor whitmer can have an imagination
and it's what makes us
this is every single solitary generation
that died
you're black man country slavery unless
we are able to treat
some [ __ ] we're just never going to get
a vote for you they want to put you back
in chains
do you like to see that happen green
i used to think racial jungle not
anymore by the way you want his kids to
be raised in a
racial jungle joe biden said according
to politifact
you remember when trump was doing that
series of tweets where he just said a
couple of words and then just said
vote i imagined at that time that biden
was like guys let me do this one they're
like no sir you can't just say slavery
by the way can i say slavery and then
the next tweet
be bad i'm a little confused we're a
country of slaves
that were brought here 400 years ago i
hope
that are are there still people alive
that were slaves is that what you're
insinuating
well my question is who's soldier
doesn't say well that's a good point as
well but i don't think his answer made
any sense he was just like
slavery that was also the top of his
forehead looks like it's made of damn
pipeline wants us to be usually
you know the president's commander of
the world respect has been divide and
conquered
the way he does better if he splits us
you just answered about
slavery to a completely non-slavery
related question
because the guy had a slightly darker
shade of skin and you're going to
complain about divide and conquer
you crazy old demented circus monkey
damn what's a steak
and it's not about he's gonna see next
next question gonna be some guy come up
with a roman nose
ah you know the jews aren't half bad
americans
you notice how biden is doing the same
thing that hillary did which is he got
up there and he's saying
he's dividing the country well he just
happened to divide the country into a
way that allowed him to win
an election right so here you're saying
oh he's divided but you're ignoring
first century
black folks for trump hispanic folks for
trump women for trump
because you're saying oh you shouldn't
we'll be right look there's not a single
fact wow
we just let him just run over okay uh
we'll be taking your chats by the way
after this show at londoncar.com club on
the blaze tv
uh it is crowder town hall please do
consider supporting us because this is
the only way that we get to stay in
business as you well know especially
with what's going on right now
with uh hunter biden and social media
deciding that they're going to throttle
truth
so uh that was credit.com club it's the
only way that we get to keep this going
and uh we'll be
taking your chats exclusively after the
remainder of this town hall
did we miss anything there uh reg the
bandit
no i don't think so i was going to
mention however from earlier
with the supreme court questions biden
claimed
that judge amy coney didn't lay out her
judicial philosophy during the senate
hearings this week she clearly did
and of course yeah i mean she said she
was originally originally
listed and everything so that yeah that
that that was another
issue that he slightly budged but he was
confused like you know they asked her
about
hey they asked her hey sounds like harry
kane hey
yes they asked amy coney baron about her
judicial philosophy
and she started talking about text fonts
man
she mentioned helvetica ariel i don't
care how you
type i don't know how you vote
by the way i have a follow-up question
to something he just said uh how did
donald trump divide the country
uh a record from the from the party that
is known for identity politics for
finding a wedge and pushing people apart
what donald trump did is said
you're entitled to more of your money
you're entitled to better health care
you're entitled to have troops come home
and you're entitled to have more freedom
that's divisive you know who divided the
country cnn when they rejected
ice cube because he had the gall to meet
with donald trump
because he wanted to offer this contract
for black america and donald trump was
the only one who said yes yes
who said he would arrest that this is
ice cream he said i will arrest that i
would arrest that [ __ ]
talk which is kind of ironic right
because the guy who says [ __ ] the police
uh exactly it's about donald trump and
then he offered the black contract for
america to both biden and donald trump
and the biden people said we'll get back
to you after election and donald trump
said
hey come on over what do you like code
45
they didn't ban it because of are we
there yet too that was they should have
that that was different
no that is yeah they said they said uh
we can't let you uh
come on this network anymore because of
rv2 [ __ ] that was robin williams
we're sorry we don't see color yeah
close and uh
i mean they let the dnc conference go on
i mean that was a worse production i
mean it was that was
terrible the convention i mean have we
seen we forgotten that it was not that
long ago
and this is the like these are the
answers you're hearing from biden
he's had all this time very low energy
too you know but i will say i gotta i
have to reiterate one criticism is the
very first debate
could have been just like this yeah if
trump would have just let
biden blather yeah and you know look i
understood i understand why he was
passionate in that first debate
the president i understood why he was
getting in there and you know wanting to
say his piece
but look at how terrible biden is when
he's by himself when he has to just try
and say
one sentence that makes anything which
by the way i'm actually interested
uh the number of questions to donald
trump versus biden and we're going to
average them out for 10 minutes because
it seems like they're
i don't know maybe we can figure this
out seems to me like there are a lot
more uh there are quite a few
uh more commercial breaks in the binding
town hall and questions
well we talked about how badly trump
came off at the last debate
but savannah guthrie comes off just as
bad yeah
the team came off pretty
that's what you do if you want to rattle
somebody you get personal right uh and
uh then he
really actually and this is one thing i
will say about donald trump
when you take the lie from the media
about there were fine people on both
sides you said i'm not talking about
whites okay let me go remind me to go
back
okay go back to this point about find
people on both sides because they had a
point to make compared to savannah
guthrie versus the people asked
questions as well
during that town hall meeting he was
asked several times whether he took a
covet test the day of your life oh my
god
wow a week from tonight um just two
quick questions
debate to happen will you demand that
president did you get a text from her
husband
george should be negative before you
debate yeah by the way before i came up
here
i took another test i've been taking
every day the deep test you know when
they grown both
oh women and because i wanted to be able
if i had not
passed that tested the one i told them
to get in there and they said we don't
need you to take off your pants i said i
could take it i just think it's
uh so this isn't an issue it's just
decency
i want to be able to determine whether
or not you are
you're clear and it's not i'm less
concerned about very low-end people
the guys of the cameras the people
working in the you know
the the they're of no real secret
services guys you drive up with all
those people
and so yes i i i believe he'll do that i
look i'm so i want to know i believe he
will do what what is he talking
[Music]
and secret service being around so when
biden potentially may have been infected
did he
decide to say no no security what
happened to trusting the science
and the medical professionals because
the doctor said that donald trump tested
negative several times
yeah well those doctors there and he was
clear to debate tonight
those that was actually clear i think
they're going to not like what happened
last time
by the way can i just make a quick point
every single video that i have seen him
talking to the press in
he is wearing a mask and that's
fantastic one he's wearing it wrong and
two
he is actually more of a danger to
everyone when he does this
every time he touches it he's touching
it and then touching a doorknob or
shaking a hand or putting his hand
it would be better if he didn't have a
mask wait he is a super spreader by
doing that yeah that's what people do
is this the end of it course voting
already underway more than 18 million
americans have voted
tonight as you heard from the vice
president everyone was supposed to be a
presidential debate president trump
pulled out of that debate when the
commission wanted a virtual debate
after the covet outbreak at the white
house joe biden had agreed
uh to do that instead then doing the
town all here with abc and the president
in a late move this week agreeing to the
town hall and another network okay so it
is over okay sorry finish your point
that wasn't well that was anticlimactic
i can't believe it well what do you mean
it was perfectly climactic for joe biden
no they broke in and basically they were
saying this is really boring we're gonna
have to break in and tell you something
look at him he looks so confused
he looks like a parakeet when you take
the sheet off the cage
all right so so bill you made this point
just a minute ago it wasn't just that he
got softball questions from the audience
i think the first person that asked a
question that we went to was on foreign
policy that guy was obviously somebody
who leaned pro-republican
there was no hard questioning from
stephanopoulos there was no follow-up
from
anybody in the audience asking a
follow-up question at all or a follow-up
from stephanopoulos on anything they
said
joe biden didn't say uncontroversial
things either it's not by the way those
people are not social distancing
i think it's you know so look
first of all every time we went to a
break they were cutting them off but the
one moment
when they were asking about fracking
yeah and george was like
no about fracking no no but you should
answer
please answer right okay we'll just get
we'll just move like he was in a
nightmare where he was trying to yell
yeah i want to be honest
he could have just said hey you're crazy
and not answering
yeah and he tried but then he stopped
trying and then he was just like no all
right
that was the biggest moment though right
right that was the one moment where it
looked
somewhat like he was doing his job but
not really pressing hard enough okay
well i wanted to make this final point
and then
i i wanted to make two points here
actually okay um
first one that lady who asked him a
question about dreamers about
daca uh uh i believe that was to joe
biden the day magnolia lady
this is one thing i was just thinking
about the other day when because i just
watched vampires in the bronx on netflix
did you see it yet quarterback that was
it was to trump yeah i was it so it was
about it was a
was it for donald trump donald trump it
was uh was it the day later or i think
she asked a different question
oh no way that's right it was to him and
then he was talking about the difference
between dreamer
sorry i was thinking about dreamers and
daca she conflated the two because
dame edna does um anyways so vampires in
the bronx
or vampires vampire in the bronx
whatever it was called brooklyn uh
no it was vampire in the bronx that's
how unoriginal gosh
which by the way you want to talk about
a negative stereo like
black oh that was good it's not that i
don't think that they can just take
white films and put in black people is
that i think that black americans
deserve better than
hey fright night with black people
that's what vampires in the bronx is but
it's basically
uh uh about vampires but it's
effectively one big analogy right for
uh gentrification and they complain
about gentrification
and they talk about this and this lady
was short i don't remember exactly what
triggered it for me but she was and i
mean that in the actual way not in
trigger warning
um asking about daca and dreamers this
is something that's come up quite a bit
in these
debates and these conversations about
gentrification um no one talks about
this at all but i was talking
i was watching vampire in the bronx and
then i was listening to aoc recently
hold on a second when people complain
about gentrification
what they're primarily complaining about
is white people obviously moving into an
area this is what they say
vampires in the bronx they say when
white people move in and then we gotta
be
we get priced out are you sure that was
always an entirely black neighborhood
and that's what triggered it she said
she was a russian immigrant because
guess what
hamtramck before you heard the muslim
call to prayer as you do now in michigan
look it up it's one place in the united
states where you can hear the muslim
called a prayer five times
a day was a polish neighborhood many
areas of brooklyn or the bronx
were polish were italian were irish and
then they moved away
and black people moved into that
neighborhood and gentrified it when the
polish
and the irish moved out so this idea
that gentrification only occurs when
white people move in now well one second
did you gentrify it when that area let's
say hamtramck
all of a sudden the polls are no longer
there the pollocks and by the way we can
say that it's not even considered a slur
despite the fact that it's very
offensive
this is something we never now here's
one thing i think the main difference as
to why
is when you look at a lot of these
groups of people and again these are
people who are all very oppressed right
people who came across on ships people
who
were were absolute there was prejudice
against the irish against
jews of course the lower east side
alphabet city was
was by and large jews you want to say
they weren't discriminated against
even in world war ii a lot of americans
didn't like jews despite the fact that
we fought against hitler a lot of people
don't know that read some documents from
henry ford
his private letters for crying out loud
well what happened is
then the jews often would work their way
up and then they moved to the upper west
side now that's considered a very jewish
area
this is the first time because
gentrification is actually a problem
right now
of people who want to stay in
neighborhoods regardless of pricing
regardless of economic output regardless
of what they are contributing to that
neighborhood
and they want people who would like to
move into that neighborhood and to help
it
be punished not be allowed to this is
the first of gentrification now is a
byproduct of people
who want legislation to preserve a
neighborhood rather than let
the american racial melting pot occur
organically and it's amazing to me
when people say gentrification i was
watching vampire in the bronx are you
sure
that you don't live in some dirty old
pollock's house are you sure that that
area was always entirely black and we
need to blame white people for coming in
and wanting to set up a p
a a nut butter shop and the other the
other the other point that i want to get
to and then we'll go to the uh
we'll go to the uh costume contest
winner yep and we also got to
we ask our chat question yes our chat
what is our chat question we're going to
be asking we're
want people to talk about what is the
issue that biden is taking in this
election that makes you most concerned
for your family i want to ask a
corollary question right what's the
issue
that trump is talking about that makes
you most excited about his presidency
right okay that's a good question we'll
be taking that uh lot of credit.com
mug club the other point uh that i was
making what was the other thing i said
to remind me of
about the uh oh fine people oh yes on
both sides okay
so that's one that's really important
because first off two things
it highlights the media hypocrisy it
highlights how not even hypocrisy
just how blatantly dishonest uh the
media is right donald trump
after charlottesville said i'm not
talking about neo-nazis or white
supremacists
who should be condemned totally okay
but there were fine people on both sides
to me
that when taken in context is actually a
beautiful thing and is
such a contrast to joe biden tonight let
me explain what i mean
when the lady asked about daca when you
had people ask donald trump questions
that were meant to be somewhat gotcha
questions
he never actually answered to people
with any kind of revulsion at all
the only problem he had was with
savannah guthrie whereas when you
watched
joe biden answer these questions where
he had a couple of tough questions he
had a question about the
uh uh the foreign policy of donald trump
right he was pissed at that person in
the audience
let's let's also by the way compare that
to let's see if it's consistent with
with joe biden saying those people
shouldn't vote for me when someone asks
them saying hey 56
of americans think they're better off
now than they were under eight years of
obama what would you say to those
americans they shouldn't vote for me
those people are too stupid to vote this
is what he says all the time
joe biden and let's go back to hillary
clinton it is the philosophy of the dnc
they revile half of the american public
baskets of deplorables
well they're stupid they shouldn't vote
for me the way he treated people asking
him questions today the only person
donald trump had a fight with tonight
the only person he had a problem with
was the upper lipless savannah guthrie
because she wasn't doing her
job and when you go back to what they've
tried to turn into his achilles heel i
think it's donald trump's
strong suit he condemned neo-nazis he
condemned white supremacists
and then he said but there were fine
people on both sides meaning in context
there were fine people on the side of
the charlottesville protest
who wanted to tear statues down even
though donald trump disagreed with them
he was giving them the benefit of the
doubt saying
there were fine people with differing
points of view
on both sides and this is something that
should be permissible
he doesn't hate half of america he hates
the elites
who wields their power inappropriately
and of course he would hate joe biden
who says he's going to introduce a mass
mandate and he's not beholden to the
constitution joe biden
the dnc they answer time and time again
basket of deplorables
60 56 of americans are stupid they have
bad memories they shouldn't vote for me
well donald trump actually doesn't
deserve credit
let me educate you on the foreign policy
question tonight whereas donald trump
said
you know what and actually there's a
difference between dreamers and daca
which i'm sure you know better than most
people
he praised he uplifted the american
people he only swats down people in
positions of authority
that's a huge [ __ ] difference america
between two people
that's why people talked about dreading
the swamp you may unders you may think
that donald trump's a billionaire
got it you may think that he bumps
elbows with other wealthy people
absolutely
but you cannot find donald trump hating
fighting and denigrating half of america
even the half
who don't vote for him the last two
democratic candidates did by name
basket of deplorables they shouldn't
vote for me guess what
take by netta's word and then listen to
donald trump let's go to live chat at
loudoutcredit.com
club you can watch us live with the
blaze we're gonna take your chat and
announce
the costume contest winner we appreciate
you very much being here tonight i want
to hear what you think of these two town
halls
below who did better did it affect the
election youtube
i'd say we love you but we know you're
in cahoots with facebook and twitter
and you can go fornicate yourselves with
a wire brush